[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVE WILLIAMS: Have you ever
heard of the 80-20 rule?
While its roots are in economics
and process improvement,
it's found its way into popular culture.
The basic idea is that with
everything we are trying to improve,
80% of the problem or opportunity
lies with 20% of the reasons.
So what is a Pareto chart?
Well, let's take a look.
A Pareto chart is both
a bar and a line chart.
So we're going to draw this up.
And it has two axes.
So there's the y-axis
on the left hand side.
We got our x-axis.
And then we've got another
y-axis on the right hand side.
On the right hand side is the
percentage in which something occurs.
So we're just going to try
to keep it simple here.
We'll put 100%, 50%, and
then just down here at 0.
On the left hand side, this is the
frequency in which an issue occurs.
So again, we'll try to
keep it simple here.
And we'll go with 10,
5, and that would be 0.
And then along the bottom, we list
the categories or defects of issues
that we're seeing.
So A, B, C, D, E. And
I'll just put the defects.
Now as we're tracking our data from
a collection form, we'll look at it
and we'll say, well gosh, how
many did we have of each of these?
And we try to list these in the order
in which is most frequent to least
frequent.
So it's showing you from big to small.
So if we think of Defect
A, let's imagine that we
had 8 of Defect A. Defect B, we had 5.
Defect C, we only had about 3.
Defect D, there was maybe 2.
And Defect E had 1.
So again, we'll-- And then there's
another piece that's a line chart.
And that's where the
percentages come in.
And what we're trying to do is identify
what percentage of the total problem
is each of the defects, so we can try
to see which is the most common to least
common.
We're looking for that 80-20 rule.
So imagine we've got this line chart.
And we'll just say that,
if this is 80 here,
if we work on these
particular defect, we
can expect that we can actually make
the biggest improvement in our process.
And so it's a great
place for us to start
doing our PDSA testing and some
of our other tools and methods
to identify opportunities
for improvement.
So the idea here is to look at the
issues with the biggest effect--
the vital few 20%-- and focus
your improvements there first.
If successful, your initial improvements
will make the biggest difference.
Pareto charts are very easy to
create in any spreadsheet program
and are helpful for converting check
sheet and cause and effect data
into knowledge.
It helps focus improvement efforts
on the vital few opportunities
for improvement and can
help you make a big impact.